[Musique]
beaucoup de confrères reçoivent
actuellement des appels de leurs clients
qui demandent s'ils peuvent ou doivent
nettoyer les coussinets de leur chien au
retour de promenade voir désinfecter
leurs chats avec du gel hydroalcoolique
donc non ne faites pas ça l'eau de javel
est toxique pour nous pour nos animaux
pour l'environnement donc on n'utilisera
pas et quant au gel hydroalcoolique
il a une toxicité transcutanée sur les
chats donc surtout pas et sur les chiens
aussi et puis il peut devenir aussi
toxiques parce que les chats et les
chiens quand il n'aime pas quelque chose
il le laisse donc ils ingèrent donc ce
sont des produits évidemment à ne pas à
ne pas utiliser
les propriétaires qui ont tenté
désinfecter régulièrement utilisé la
solution hydro alcoolique ou là de javel
ce qui a pu amener dans les cas les plus
graves des comas éthyliques notamment
chez le chat par léchage mais également
des brûlures des couleurs qui peuvent
être graves au niveau des consignes et
quand on voit l'utilisation de la
solution hydro alcoolique sur le
proprement imaginer ce que ça peut faire
sur un animal domestique air
[Musique]
bien
au couteau
quel ennui
[Musique]